[Music]
a military exercise in the western
pacific this month u.s warships sailing
alongside allied ships highlights the
growing concern over china's military
buildup the secretary of the navy now
says that china is the most significant
long-term challenge for the u.s military
bar none
the response includes a new effort to
support aircraft carriers of course a
symbol of u.s military power for nearly
a century now
david martin shows us how the navy is
testing crewless aircraft that could
give its planes a much needed and much
longer range
an f-18 fighter comes up behind an
airplane known as the mq-25
and makes aviation history the first
ever aerial refueling from an unmanned
aircraft a game of inches played at 250
miles per hour this is the first time
looking over at where a cockpit and a
person should be and just seeing nothing
but more airplane lieutenant william
peabody was flying that f-18 did it make
you uneasy a little at first because
when you're flying on another manned
aircraft you know there's an inherent
level of trust you have with that
aircrew but we don't have that so far
with mq-25
until now the navy has used other f-18s
fitted with fuel tanks under their wings
as flying gas stations for their carrier
aircraft
it's a waste of a high performance jet
designed for combat
which is one reason rear admiral brian
corey is leading a crash program to
switch to unmanned fueling with the
mq-25
and what's it carrying inside there
almost all gas it doesn't burn much
itself and it can give most of that gas
away to our fighters so this is where
the fuel comes out this is the business
end
the mq-25 carries enough gas to double
the range of today's carrier aircraft
including the navy's newest f-35
that matters because countries like
china are building land-based missiles
capable of striking aircraft carriers
forcing them to stay further and further
out to sea the whole point of this
airplane is to extend the range of the
carrier striking power refueling from an
mq-25 is the easy part the hard part is
putting it on a carrier flight deck when
the wings are spread it's about 80 feet
and that's just about the maximum you
can get on an aircraft carrier
an unmanned aircraft in the midst of the
high octane ballet that takes place on a
flight deck every time planes take off
and land
each plane has to be in the right place
at the right time
being off by even a little could send
one over the side
every airplane relies for its final
safety check for someone looking out the
window and making sure you don't run
into an airplane we don't have that
the mq-25 is practicing carrier
operations at this landlocked airfield
in illinois where the plane's maker
boeing has painted the outline of a
carrier deck it's being controlled by
the man in the green shirt using that
console on his forearm
he's following signals from the man in
the yellow vest who is directing the
mq-25 as it moves about the field the
flight deck of a carrier is one of the
most dangerous work environments in the
world lieutenant commander eric smith is
working with a simulator launching an
mq-25 from a virtual deck
keenan aiken is at the controls taking
his cues from a virtual man in yellow if
you can play a game console you'll be
able to operate this deck control device
he's telling it which way to turn based
off the hand signals given by the yellow
shirt right now he's doing the wing
spread symbol so you're going to see the
wings spread here shortly once the mq-25
takes off it flies a pre-programmed
route to its refueling station
where it would top off the tanks of the
carrier's combat aircraft starting in
2025 the navy plans to put five
mq-25s costing about 100 million dollars
a piece on every aircraft carrier this
drone is really about a lot more than
just aerial refueling it is about
finding a new way to operate from an
aircraft carrier and finding a way for
aircraft carriers to be able to survive
to remain relevant is what i would say
and yes survive
if the mq-25 works it's only a matter of
time before the navy puts more unmanned
aircraft on its carriers to carry out
strikes against heavily defended targets
where a manned aircraft would not
survive nate
david thank you so much it's hard to
conceptualize technology in the navy
meeting but we do know it will help
protect this country